es el primer sondeo desde el inicio de
la campaña electoral en brasil según la
encuestadora datafolha el ex presidente
y candidato izquierdista luiz inácio
lula da silva obtendría un 47% de los
sufragios frente al 32% del actual
mandatario jair bolsonaro una distancia
que no ha parado de estrecharse
la brecha entre luna y bolsonaro se ha
reducido y hasta ha sido en la tendencia
desde mayo todavía hay un margen sólido
de 15 puntos porcentuales en la primera
vuelta lo que dejaría el ex presidente
lula en una posición como la de
los últimos datos reflejados por la
demoscopia indican que el apoya a
bolsonaro ha crecido tres puntos
porcentuales respecto al mes anterior
una tendencia consolidada ya que desde
diciembre del año pasado cuando empezó a
sonar el nombre de lula como candidato
el derechista le ha recortado 29 puntos
de confirmarse las estimaciones brasil
no escaparía de la segunda vuelta y
viese ahí donde la encuestadora da una
ventaja de 17 puntos al candidato del
partido de los trabajadores unos datos
que no convencen al electorado bolsón
arista
no creo que los resultados vayan a ser
así en la segunda vuelta bolsonaro será
ganador la campaña electoral de los
comicios más polarizados en décadas
arrancó el martes en la que se
contrapondrán dos modelos para el país
amparados por el populismo de derecha de
bolsonaro respaldados por los
conservadores cristianos y las
propuestas socialistas de lula un líder
sindical que fue encarcelado por
corrupción hasta que la justicia anuló
sus condenas el 2 de octubre la decisión
está en manos de los más de 156 millones
de electores